[Música]
pero si ustedes ven acá no es una
artista
esto es como yo llegué a pensar en algún
momento se debía haber un artista yo
creo que existe este paradigma que la
artista tiene que verse diferente tiene
que usar colores cadenas lentes graves
definidos lugares cerrados y todo este
concepto que lo que -20 es cuando en una
foto así es a un emprendedor pero yo
creo que todo artista que ha logrado
tener éxito ese factor común es que al
final tuvieron la visión que tiene un
emprendedor y quiero arrancar
contándoles un poquito de esta
apasionante industria que la verdad yo
me ha gustado cada etapa del camino pero
que muchos no entienden cómo funciona
siempre me preguntan pero de dónde viene
la música de dónde nace una canción y la
realidad es que es un proceso mágico es
un proceso que empieza de forma que
cuesta poner en palabras porque
realmente la inspiración viene del más
allá
te agarra desprevenido no sé en el super
me ha pasado todo en el super y de
repente se me viene la idea de una
canción y agarro mi celular me a una
esquina y la empiezo a cantar y la gente
me ve como raro de que está haciendo
esta oa veces incluso a medio sueño
estoy soñando me levanto y digo lo tengo
que grabar que si no se va a olvidar y
poco a poco pues estas pequeñas ideas
que van surgiendo uno las va volviendo
música las va volviendo canciones a
veces sólo a veces con un grupo de
personas de compositores que al final es
súper mágico porque uno empieza una
frase y el otro la termina sin decir una
palabra y poco a poco pues uno escribe
un sinnúmero de canciones que después no
todas llegan al público no todas las
llegan a escuchar ustedes pero las pocas
que uno elige para que los representen a
uno como artista uno se va a la fábrica
de producción que después de al final el
estudio de grabación donde se encarga
uno no solo de darle forma en ritmo en
letra que hay muchas personas
involucradas en el proceso músicos del
productor sino al final es como
plasmamos ese sentimiento que inspiró a
escribir una canción
para que la gente que lo escuche no
importa si no entiende por eso dicen que
la música es un lenguaje universal pueda
sentirlo y una vez uno tiene la canción
uno pasa a hacer un vídeo muchos creen
que el vídeo no es importante pero al
final del vídeo es como esa
representación visual de lo que te llevo
y te inspiró a escribir la canción y ya
cuando uno tiene pues este producto como
cualquier producto de cualquier
emprendedor uno hace un plan de
lanzamiento qué fecha va a salir cuál es
el plan de expectativa en qué medios se
va a uno a presentar si hay entrevista
en radio en prensa en redes sociales y
poco a poco pues todo esto que les
cuento acá no les voy a mentir cuando
uno arranca como artista y uno tiene
este sueño de convertirse en un gran
artista lo primero que uno piensa son
las disqueras las disqueras para los que
no saben pues son estos dinosaurios que
llevan años en la industria que tienen
todo el know-how que tienen todas pues
al final la experiencia los contactos y
entonces uno dice lo que yo quiero es
que me firme una disquera para que lleve
esa música ese talento al rededor del
mundo y en lo personal les quiero contar
una anécdota
esto arrancó para mí en la ciudad de los
ángeles hollywood los ángeles la ciudad
donde los sueños se hacen realidad pues
bien porque todo todo todo mi esfuerzo
en poderme ir a estudiar allá con la
excusa realmente de ir a estudiar pero
yo quería lograr que una izquierda me
viera y me firmara y me convirtiera
pertenece artista al final internacional
que toda la gente pudiera reconocer pero
cuando llegué allá me empecé a reunir
con diferentes representantes de
izquierdas managers empecé a entender
cómo funcionaba la industria y
básicamente me dijeron hay dos formas
hay artistas que las disqueras firman
porque quieren probar probemos que esta
persona cante esto se vista así hable
así creemos un producto con esta persona
y veamos cómo nos va y por otro lado
porque eso no era lo que yo quería se
podrán imaginar yo entrada a las
reuniones me vean canchita soy como bien
energética y me decían ay tu seguro
tantas así pop vestía rosado esa faldita
los chunguitos y decía como que vino eso
sí no soy yo pero decía yo quiera algo
profundo y me decían bueno si al final
quieres hacer tu arte
tu música tenés que empezar tu sola
saturn show tenés que empezar tú como un
emprendedor probar que tu producto
funciona y tal vez más adelante entonces
venga una disquera y diga yo quiero
invertir y llevarte a otro nivel y
entonces me tocó arrancar le tocó
encender ese primer fósforo y tratar de
empezar a descifrar el camino yo había
ahorrado por muchísimos años para poder
hacer mi primer disco y cuando llegué
allá no me alcanzó pero ni para dos
canciones así que ya estando allá me
tocó usar un recurso que hoy en día
super conocido que es el crowdfunding
pero en ese entonces no se conocía y
mucho menos en el ámbito musical
al final pues hice una campaña una
campaña bien genuina donde le contaba a
mis seguidores cercanos a mis amigos a
familiares a través de un vídeo sobre
esta loca guatemalteca que se ha venido
a los ángeles a perder su sueño de hacer
su música una música que mandará un
mensaje que pudiera conectar con gente
de diferentes lados del mundo y pues al
final este fue la primera puerta que me
abrió el mundo a un artista
independiente a una emprendedora como a
mí me gusta verlo porque me tocó hacer
cosas que ustedes nunca se imaginarán un
artista hace ver a uno piensa el artista
llega canta después va al vídeo canta y
después desde la comodidad de su casa
lanza el material y ahí está y su
stories en riesgo sea liberal pero al
final hubieron muchas cosas detrás que
hoy en día yo las cuentas me dan hasta
risa o sea desde tener que no poder
pagar un catering para el vídeo entonces
tener que ir al súper hacer sanguchitos
hacer los postres empacarlo para que se
viera todo profesional y del día del
vídeo hasta inventarme un correo como si
yo fuera una productora diferente a la
artista y conseguir así los actores que
van a salir en el vídeo
o negociar diferentes contratos con
marcas hasta haber hecho la primera gira
yo solita y llegar a las entrevistas y
decir vengo a entrevista y me decían ya
qué artista trae un acuerdo rebién jilín
salvador en otros países decía a mí y la
gente era como se mata de la risa porque
era algo que es poco usual el artista
siempre va representado por alguien es
el que no habla mucho a veces hasta usa
lentes verá dentro de todo esto parte de
esas falsas expectativas son los números
en redes sociales hoy en día la gente
mide el éxito con los números en redes
sociales sea un artista exitoso para una
disquera incluso hoy en día para muchas
personas tales para muchos de los que
están ahí sentados es cuántos views
tiene cuántos plays cuántos likes
cuántos followers ya mí incluso me ha
pasado que me gusta repente alguien
cantando me meto a su perfil y uno ve
tres mil seguidores y automáticamente
uno dice ah no está empezando y se sale
yo digo el nombre como así y me vuelvo a
meter a chequear porque es como este
paradigma que han creado de pensar que
el éxito se mide con estos números
con 1 lanza su material 1 está empezando
a emprender lanza con toda esta energía
de trabajo que uno hace y se topa con
esto era esta cara de decir a la gran
apenas tuve 2000
al principio verdad me acuerdo que me
tomó mucho tiempo en llegar a mis
primeros 10.000 views y cuando llegue a
los 10.000 era como anna sólo son 10.000
y ustedes van a pensar 10.000 es un
montón pero uno se empieza a comparar
con por ejemplo yo tenía amigos que de
repente fueron firmados por disqueras
lanzando material sin que nadie los
conociera sin haber hecho mucho trabajo
y de repente subían ya un post que decía
un millón de vídeos en 24 horas y uno
decía en la granja como hizo es lo era
yo llevo meses tratando y no llegó pero
ni siquiera los 20 mil entonces empieza
a toda esta frustración que te hace
perder un poco el enfoque y yo les
cuento esto porque es un aprendizaje que
he tenido que aplica para cualquier
emprendedor y que al final una vez no lo
comparte verá más en el mundo del
entretenimiento que a veces puede
parecer un poco ácido y un poco irreal
y dentro de todo esto pues nace la
famosa frase feickert you may que a mí
me la dijeron mil veces tenés que
pretender ser un artista super famoso
para que otros te vean como famoso y
todo lo que conlleva ver a donde puse a
leer un montón de artículos de cómo
realmente poder subir los números cambio
el enfoque el enfoque ya no era como
hace una mejor música como mejoro mis
canciones con que otra gente de la
industria me puede relacionar que me
ayuda a crecer mi producto sino al final
es como parezco exitoso era cómo puedo
elevar estos números y poco a poco no
les voy a mentir yo investigué y
aprendió todo aprendí que se puede
comprar seguidores y que si compra
seguidores hay que comprar likes hay que
comprar followers para que te vea real y
se compran views y se compran plays y
todo este mundo que al final no les va a
mentir yo pasé todo el proceso y llegué
hasta el final y cuando me tocaba pagar
era como ay me dolía tanto adaptar tanto
dinero en gente que era irreal que
gracias a dios nunca lo hice pero algo
que sí hice fue que sacrifique mí
a mí me decían con música baladas y
letras no vas a pegar tenés que hacer
reggaeton tenés que vender más piel
tenemos que decirte más llamativa yo
decía música bueno tarde si va puede ser
entonces empecé a hacer música con esos
beats urbanos con letras que tal vez no
me identificaba tanto gracias a dios
nunca me fui al extremo de mostrar 100%
piel si no me fui pero si fue algo donde
yo digo hoy esas canciones no me
arrepiento pero no soy yo y se topa uno
en ese punto donde uno dice 11 12
estados fracasan el porcentaje artistas
que fracasa no sólo en la música sino en
general es mucho más alto y porque
verdad está esta pregunta porque llega
ese punto donde amas tanto algo pero
estás dispuesto a dejarlo porque es más
la frustración que la pasión y ahí es
donde yo siento que toca servirse y toca
hacer esa pregunta de decir de verdad
prefiero dejar esto por la frustración
que me generan cosas y métricas vacías
como
a veces tal vez nos de los números en
redes sociales o toda esta imagen que
uno se hace de lo que es un artista
famoso estoy dispuesto a regresar back
to basics a regresar al famoso ua y ver
al famoso porque empecé en esto porque
monté mi empresa porque hemos tenido
socio que me hace diferente que me hace
único y como artista especialmente que
es lo que te diferencia a ti sos muy
buen compositor hago música que tiene un
mensaje especial y entonces cuando
regresas a esto yo tuve tres
aprendizajes que por más que ahorita les
cuento la parte como dura y la parte
difícil yo me he gozado ser una artista
independiente de ser un artista
emprendedor en cierto punto y tratar de
descifrar el camino un poco mientras uno
va avanzando pero hay tres aprendizajes
que yo siento aplican en la música en el
arte y en cualquier emprendimiento que
hay que tenerlos bien presentes desde
que uno empieza y sobre todo mientras se
va poniendo más difícil el camino porque
aún no se le olvida a mí se me olvidó y
primero yo diría que será auténtico
hoy en día la gente no se enamora un
producto no se enamora una canción de un
ritmo se enamora de la persona de la
filosofía detrás de eso o sea la gente
conecta con el sentimiento conecta con
el porque tú haces tu arte con porque
todos tú no con el ego de decir es el
famosísimo y ahí va en el centro
comercial con lentes que nadie se te
acerque que era lo que me decían a mí
que tenía que hacer porque yo lo harás
que nunca ha sido tan fashionista ahí
vea en el primer vídeo vestía colores y
todo porque era un poco yo tratando de
jugar este rol de artista verdad pero
ser auténtico ser lo que tú sos en
cualquier producto en cualquier ambiente
segundo saber que es un camino distinto
para cualquier persona
yo tengo ejemplos miren yo fui artista
independiente tengo amigos muy cercanos
que siguieron la ruta de la disquera que
pensaron que les iban a resolver la vida
y después de unos años y de haber
invertido millones en sus vídeos en sus
campañas de haber logrado sus famosos
millones y millones de views llegó un
punto donde las disqueras mismas dijeron
bueno muchas gracias no funciona el
producto y chau
y después están desde cero y me acuerdo
que me decían me toca empezar ahora como
a emprender en la música con un artista
independiente y no tengo ni idea de cómo
funciona de que hago de cómo venderme y
entonces digo este aprendizaje de decir
que quieres tu verdad quieres realmente
empezar por tu cuenta y tratar de
adquirir todo esto conocimiento que por
más que uno falla en el camino uno se
levanta y uno sigue caminando o querés
delegar selo alguien más y decir tengo
la idea hacer tú todo y contarme cómo
vamos avanzando a después ya un punto
donde esa persona se va y te quedás del
medio de la nada
y tercero puede empezar especialmente yo
creo que cuando es en el arte es en un
campo pues que a uno le apena a veces
compartir o a veces emprendedores mismos
que les da pena compartir sus ideas
porque les da miedo ser juzgados o le da
miedo qué va a pensar la otra gente yo
creo que hay que empezar para que
ustedes se rían yo creo que al final los
paradigmas siempre van a existir yo me
acuerdo que a mí en eeuu yo era la
canchita que debería cantar de rosado y
las colitas y acá en los latinos el
mercado latino era como ay esa ni es
latina pues tú que es cancha y el plano
que es como estar cantando latino y
decía los paradigmas de las etiquetas
siempre van a existir
lo importante es tu ser auténtico con lo
que tú sos
y quiero pues firme este momento porque
si a mí me hubieran enseñado esta foto
cuando yo empecé y me hubieran dicho
mira en cinco años tú vas a estar
cantando en los emmys ibas a estar pues
lanzando una de tus canciones ahí y vas
a hacer el primer show latino que por
fin pues al final está en la gala en la
cena que hacen o que me hayan dicho mira
tú vas a ser una de las cuatro artistas
con que inició la segunda temporada del
show de force on fox que al final está
escondida cali fergie
diría yo era dicho a las que increíbles
a quien tengo que conocer para que me
lleve ahí
a qué persona o qué porque yo no conozco
a nadie que pueda realmente abrirme esa
puerta
y al final si se dan cuenta pues todo
esto a mí me preguntan siempre mira
quién fue el manager que te logros as
oportunidades o quién fue la persona que
te las abrió y ustedes se podrán reír
pero creo que eso fue llegando yo solita
con lo que iba construyendo como
emprendedor a estas puertas que uno
abriendo y que como steve jobs decía no
se pueden conectar los puntos viendo
hacia adelante solo cuando uno ve hacia
atrás y una persona una puerta después
te lleva a otra y poco a poco vas
construyendo tu propia carrera porque tú
estás en control se vale fallar no hay
ningún emprendedor artista exitoso que
te diga yo siempre fui perfecto pues yo
nunca falla no tuve errores se falla
muchas veces se pierde dinero a veces lo
importante es que no sea tanto pero yo
creo que al final importante es una
aprender crecer y encontrarte a ti y
saber que te va a tocar abrir mil
puertas pero poco a poco cada puerta que
vayas abriendo te va a llevar a
encontrar lo que tú sos a ser diferente
ya no tener miedo a emprender
emprender siendo auténtico de emprender
al final con tu arte sabiendo que no
competir con nadie más que contigo mismo
y que es un proceso que va a tomar
tiempo pero más vale vivirlo tú ir
agarrando todos esos conocimientos que
te permitan desarrollarse como persona
como artista y sobre todo empezar que es
la parte más difícil así que creo que
aunque uno uno pensará un artista no es
un emprendedor a veces vale más la pena
empezar y emprender y emprender con tu
arte que es algo tan único y sobre todo
no buscar con placer con placer los
paradigmas de lo que la gente cree que
es un artista sino al final el arte
viene de adentro y va a traer a esa
gente que resuene contigo con tu
filosofía con lo que tú sos y poco a
poco pues te abra las puertas para
grandes aventuras grandes oportunidades
que hoy darles no te imaginas que pueden
llegar
[Aplausos]